and now for the checkmate white is
trying to prepare a checkmate on the
side of the board
uh with two rooks fighting against the
queen there's a threat of
checkmating ideas uh maybe the rook oh
the the pawn in the middle hans was
relying on this pawn to become a new
queen but now it's in loads of trouble
uh we're gonna see another crazy time
scramble i have a beautiful checkmate
beautiful checkmate martinez coming in
with the comeback
and second time second time that he
saves the game that he was not supposed
to be saving meaning that hans is still
not closing the match
just bam with the chances to turn
everything around wait what is his
kingdom gonna fade him he misclicked he
wanted to castle he couldn't castle
properly because he misclicked
these players are just
so
not in the zone in a way right now